the organizers had predicted 150
000 might attend in reality it seemed
even more
london's piccadilly filled with people
as far as the eye could see
a march literally more than a mile long
a week ago the same campaign groups had
marched on the israeli embassy
demanding an end to missile attacks on
gaza friday's ceasefire
seemed to have energized these same
activists
this demonstration is to make sure that
we get more than a ceasefire out of this
that we get a real movement in the
uh attitude of the great powers and of
the israeli government
towards the palestinians that we move
towards a just settlement for the
palestinians
that sentiment is shared by activists
across europe demonstrators also massed
in bulgaria and the german capital
berlin
in paris hundreds of demonstrators
gathered in placerla republic
to unfurl an enormous palestinian flag
palestinians have been persecuted
for the past uh 73 years and there
we need to free palestine no matter
whether there's a ceasefire in place or
not at the moment
[Music]
comparison has been made with the black
lives matter movement and in the uk
there is evidence that the perceived
injustices
of israel's treatment of palestinians is
provoking a particularly strong response
among students and young adults there is
almost a sense of a new generation
of pro-palestinian campaigners emerging
i feel so proud
that so many of us yet again have come
to make a stand
for something disimportant um a lot of
people think that
this doesn't do anything a lot of people
think that we're just marching and
screaming
but there has been change and we're just
not going to stop until that change has
actually come into place and we have a
free palestine
what israel is doing is wrong there's no
one here calling for violence
we just want peace it's as simple as
that what's been most striking
about this demonstration is not just the
sheer weight of numbers on display here
but also the youthfulness of the crowd
they are predominantly in their teens
and twenties and early thirties
and they are buoyed by the belief that
the pressure that they have brought to
bear over the past two weekends
has contributed significantly to
bringing an end to the conflict in gaza
but the message they're putting out here
is that the conflict may be over
but the campaign goes on paul brennan
al jazeera central london